hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and in this video i'm going to keep
talking about order flow delta you know
overflow delta
is the difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in the
market you know it's the aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers that are
going to move the market so watching the
delta can give you clues as to potential
uh market turning points and
continuation and what i'll be talking
about today is you know one of the
patterns that i like to look for in the
delta to tell me you know the market is
turning now
the thing is with delta right every bar
has a delta and
honestly most of the time
it doesn't really have much meaning in
the sense of
telling you which way the market is
going to go yeah i mean yeah when the
market has positive delta you're
expecting the market to move up
generally or negative delta you're
expecting the market to move down there
are times where
the market is moving up on negative
delta or the market is moving down on
positive delta and that has meaning but
what i'll be talking about today is how
i use delta to find you know turning
points in the market
now
you know this is the crude oil today
well yesterday is a saturday morning
while i'm recording but this was friday
activity and you know early in the
session
um right after uh the new york
hours uh kicked in you know we had this
high up here
at uh it was at 86.39 we sold off
and you know the basically we started
going sideways for a while and
where i thought it got interesting in
the order flow
is you know around this 9 20 time you
know we sold off from you know the 86 30
area down into
the um you know 85 61 62 area but as it
was coming down right you're seeing the
market sell off on negative delta that's
what you like to see
all right you can see it's minus 100
minus 74 minus 124 minus 53 minus 10
minus 20 minus 96
minus 49 and then minus 4. so this whole
area all negative delta on the move down
yeah that's what you expect right just
as on this move up you're seeing
positive deltas right 8 115 74 41
but this is what i like to look for i
like to look for a market that is
selling off but delta
nega the negative delta that you're
seeing is still negative but it's
decreasing right and then it turns
positive then it's that's where i'm
looking for the market to rally because
you know a lot of times you just have it
like this you know minus 79 minus 46 8
right earlier even had minus 173 then
one which again is pretty much neutral
in the sense of doesn't give you any
direction but even if you were to look
here it'd be like minus 173 and kind of
a neutral bar nothing
then minus 79 minus 46 positive delta as
the market is turning and then obviously
plus 115 did the market go higher yeah a
little bit
this one is a bit more clearer what you
got is you know you have all that
negative delta then that strong push
right here i like to get a strong
delta push you know what i mean is a
strong delta uh number right and 96 is
is decent right it's very good it's
above 50.
and in the crude you know that's
you know just pushing uh well above
average you know averaging the crude is
you know about anywhere between you know
80 and and 45. so minus 96 is fits the
criteria minus 49
minus four now this is a green candle
and then six okay again you know minus
four minus six it's not the biggest
number but when you have those small
numbers again it's a sign of
evenly matched trade you know buyers and
sellers are pretty much evenly matched
you know you got decent volume 236 190
and you only end up with minus four
minus six i mean the previous bar here
only had 195 contracts and a delta minus
49.
now you got even more volume and
the delta is much less and we're sort of
coming in we made this new swing low
here right it's lower than the previous
swing low at 68. so we're trading down
you know another seven points lower
and
now we're starting to see buyers come in
right
buyers are stepping in and they're
absorbing the aggressive selling that's
going on now you're starting to see the
aggressive buyers step in six obviously
76 you know that's your sign right you
got the big push in delta and then
a little bit of continued selling
some more selling but it's being
absorbed than the aggressive buying
aggressive buying and this market
rally back up you know to our swing high
we spent a lot of time sort of in this
range you know between 60 and and 30
you just see going back and forth now
you know again there's positive deltas
there's negative deltas in here but
there's no real clear pattern right it's
kind of mixed and when you're in a
sideways market it tends to be mixed but
i like to find that sort of you know the
market's sort of coming in you'll get
that strong selling and then weaker
weaker and then start turn positive
positive
you know but again
don't be
sit there confused trying to read every
single thing look for the clear patterns
in the delta but we had been trading you
know in this tight range site range we
finally broke out of it and started
making these nice
new highs
you know up to 87 20 i don't like saying
nice new highs in crude oil because you
know that affects all of us at the gas
station i heat pain
uh my going to the gas station filling
up my tank paying 100 bucks but um
you know
market made a new high which is uh
you know what happened but later in the
day again something uh
kind of similar happened for what time
it was uh where was it here
okay here we sort of coming back up
towards the high right we had that high
at 87.20
okay so
earlier we made that high 8720 that was
around 1140 and market is sort of
working its way lower drifting down got
down to 86.50 here 86.40 again not quite
down to that 8630 area
and then starting to rally we pull back
here then we come up
start coming up in towards this high up
here at 87 20 but as we're going up
right we're going up potentially to take
out the high of the day that's what you
want to see but as we're going up right
okay we got nice delta here
plus 106
plus 41 plus 105
plus 61. we are
one tick off that high delta is only
plus 61. it's a green candle okay next
bar
it's like it's a green candle but it's
lower than the previous green candle
which is not a good sign
point of control is also lower not a
good sign
delta is less so we're going up towards
this high but delta is getting weaker
what is that telling you stop think
about it for a second all right we're
going up to the high
you want to see delta getting stronger
right you want to see if you're going to
take out that high and continue higher
but instead
it sort of fails within you know a tick
of the high and delta is getting weaker
than
the negative delta comes in here minus
74. right now it's a red candle you got
a small stacked cell and balance going
on in there next bar red candle point of
controls what's happening point controls
are migrating lower
lower point of control than previous one
lower point of control than the previous
one lower point of control than the
previous one obviously lower point of
control here
now people say but mike you got positive
delta 27.
shouldn't the market be going up and you
got again positive delta of 51.
shouldn't the market be going up oh you
got positive delta why am i seeing this
market go down well the reason why you
have the positive delta
of 27 of 51 in these red candles is
because
you have supply coming into the market
right and what that means is even though
you have the aggressive buyers
you have more supply
than demand so those aggressive buyers
are buying the offer and the people that
are selling it you know they're just
happy to work bids they're not coming in
here and hitting the bids they don't do
that until you know the market drops
from you know 8 700 another 25 cents
down to 75 when they start whacking
hitting all these bids they're just
happy because we're at the high of the
day or not at the high but we're just
below the high of the day
and you know
if you remember equities had been
rallying you know everyone wants
somebody who wants to go long into the
weekends
but these sellers you know they're not
stupid they're like hey you know what
i'm fine to sell it up here you know
87.05 87
um double oh
just to absorb whatever
leftover buying there is you know from
people that are following into the
market ahead of the weekend thinking the
market's going to
open higher on monday
that's why you have that positive delta
so you have aggressive buyers but
they're being met
by passive sellers people that are happy
to come in here and offer it out and
this is where it gets interesting is
because you know we had just been
trading higher 87 19 and the market is
coming off
and you have the sellers coming in
working offers when you have sellers
coming in working offers
strong offers on a market that's moving
down that's going to stop the market
from going higher
because now you have active
passive selling
that doesn't make sense right i mean
oxymoron active passive sellers but that
is actually a sign of aggression you
know i mean
are these orders iceberg i don't know
you know
anything in crude oil over 10 lots it's
generally iceberg so i don't know how
much they have you know in there but the
market is going down and you have strong
offers coming in to
offer resistance in the markets okay now
that's not something you're going to
pick up if you're just looking at a
normal bar chart right you need to be
looking at the order flow specifically
in the delta
to understand that and the same thing
would be true on a market that's
rallying
on
negative delta right it would basically
be telling you that you know
passive buyers are coming in to support
the market
and
you know that's just something you got
to
train yourself to look for sometimes
it's very obvious
sometimes you know it takes a little bit
of looking for but really the real big
sign that you're going to look for is
the declining positive deltas as the
markets are making high or the declining
negative deltas as the markets are
making lows
or swing highs or swing lows and then
when you add in the supply coming into
the market you know the distribution in
this case
then it just gives you that extra
confirmation of what's going to happen
next right and this market had this nice
little drop here so i hope that
teaches you something on what to look
for in the delta so that you can you
know improve your training and become a
better trader which is what it's all
about right we want to understand the
market more
so
i hope you enjoyed this video you know
be sure to
like the video be sure to you know add
your comments you know this weekend i'll
probably be making a video talking about
you know answering some of your
questions in the comments and
you know be sure to subscribe to the
channel you know i'm trying to get a
video up every day that's my goal 100
videos in 100 days so enjoy bye